eeuu el territorio con más muertes
causadas por el hobbit 19 parece empezar
a dejarlo atrás el país donde viven 328
millones de personas logro inocular 200
millones de dosis del fármaco contra el
coronavirus el 26 por ciento de la
población está totalmente vacunada
mientras que otro 40% recibió al menos
una dosis
el punto actual de la campaña que empezó
a principios de año ya superó las
expectativas de la propia casa blanca
biden había prometido alcanzar esta
cifra para sus primeros 100 días de
gobierno que se cumplen el 29 de abril
si no logramos de 'twitter' hoy llegamos
a las 200 millones de dosis el 92º el
día de mi mandato
sin embargo el 60% de los trabajadores
activos no está vacunado por lo que el
presidente estadounidense anunció
incentivos económicos a los empresarios
que permitan que sus empleados se
vacunen y recuperen en horas laborales
ningún trabajador estadounidense debería
perder ni un dólar de sueldo por elegir
cumplir con el deber ciudadano de
vacunarse no obstante la administración
de las vacunas no fue equitativa en el
territorio estadounidense especialmente
en áreas rurales donde aún hay
excepticismo al fármaco y para alcanzar
la inmunidad de rebaño es necesario que
al menos el 70 por ciento de la
población esté vacunada el ritmo de
vacunación también es desigual a escala
global las 200 millones de dosis
inoculadas en eeuu representan un 20 por
ciento de las administradas a nivel
mundial